wayne and marcia
buskie distinguished fellow in history
here at hillsdale college where he
teaches a variety of classes
every fall semester his hillsdale
teaching has included courses
on a wide variety of topics from the
ancient world to the present
he's taught courses on the second world
war classical culture
military history and leadership and this
semester he's teaching a new
course on the history of citizenship
dr hanson is also the martin ellie
anderson senior fellow in residence
in classics and military history at the
hoover institution of stanford
university where he is also a faculty
member
and where years ago he earned the phd in
classics
a prolific author professor hanson is
nationally syndicated and
column nationally syndicated columnist
and the author of hundreds of articles
reviews papers
essays editorials on topics that range
from contemporary politics
to ancient greek military history from
foreign affairs
to the practice and policy of
agriculture
but he doesn't just write about such
things as farming dr hansen has spent
years as a farmer living in california's
central valley in the house his family
has occupied for five generations
he knows how to care for orchards and
vineyards not just how to write about
them
yet he is known more for his writing
than for his almonds and raisins
he has written over two dozen books i
will not read all their titles but a few
of them
the western way of war mexifornia a
state of becoming
carnage and culture the two world wars
fields without dreams defending the
agrarian idea
his newest still unpublished book which
i've been happily reading in a draft
manuscript form that he shared with me
is titled the dying citizen
how americans are becoming something
else
in the time of plague panic and protest
this evening recognizing that today
marks the 75th anniversary of the end of
the second world war
yes 75 years ago today on the uss
missouri
the japanese surrendered that was a war
that revealed the sacrifice and
patriotism of so many
american citizens it seems fitting
therefore to consider
what american citizens are becoming if
they are indeed becoming something else
so please join me in welcoming
hillsdale's friend
and most valued colleague victor davis
hanson
that's not a good start
do i need that i don't think so um
everybody says that each election is the
most important
in their history but i think this
election is one of the
four or five most important surely if
lincoln
had not been elected in 1860 we would
have a different history had he not been
re-elected
they didn't have polls in 1864 but until
sherman took
atlanta on this day in 1864
i think george mcclellan would have won
the election
and he would have not had an
unconditional surrender and there would
have been a bifurcation of the united
states
i wasn't a big fan of franklin roosevelt
but you could argue if he would
had he not been elected in 1940 the
vinson
naval rearm and acts and a lot of the
rearment that was very crucial within
the next year or two might not have been
as steady but
this election i don't think any longer
is about trump's tweet or biden senality
it's not about progressivism versus
conservatism it's about civilization
versus anarchy
and nobody
nobody in their right mind ever thought
a wheeler dealer
manhattan raconteur would be all between
you
and what you see with the iconoclast and
the statue toppling they're
trying to remove now apparently
washington monument
renaming all these hallowed names in
american history but that's what it is
and so i'd like to just review what we
could expect
in the next 65 days
the polls are all over the place but i
think
there are polls and there are polls and
the best
adjudicator of them is how they did in
2016.
and the polls that have trump in terms
of popularity down by
10 you know what i'm talking about
reuters and politico
they're never i mean he can win by a
landslide in the poll the next day say
well he
he was down 20. it's just these are the
people who gave us
russian collusion so i don't think
there are polls that were pretty good
the zogby poll
no fan of trump was pretty good in 2016.
rasmussen is a daily a daily poll
it's a little different they get a
pre-selected audience and they stick
with them day by day they don't get
have to go out and sample each week
the emerson poll is pretty good they all
have trump in terms of favorability
within one or two
depending on the week and in terms of
biden versus trump three to four they're
in the margin of errors
but they don't matter because we're not
a direct election
nation it's the electoral college that
matters
and if you go back and look at 2016
the polls were pre some of them were
pretty accurate they said hillary would
win the popular vote by
three to five percent she won roughly by
three percent but where they really
were inaccurate with the state polls
they had
uh hillary winning all of the so-called
blue wall states
you look at those polls today and some
of them even though they were
maybe identified as conservative like
the trafalgar poll
shows trump within two points in
minnesota
and most of the pennsylvania michigan
ohio
north carolina florida polls are in
those polls are pretty close
if not in some cases trump ahead cnn
pulled all of what they called were the
11
swing states and trump was within
one point of biden so what's happening
is
this race is tightening up
and as i mentioned to someone at dinner
the way to look at this thing
is if i could use a metaphor is
trump is the captain the campaign is a
ship the port
is election day he's got to get there
and the sales
are his elect elections and campaigning
strategy
and he's had headwinds because the
commander-in-chief
is blamed for the greatest plague since
1918 in the united states he's
blamed for the first quarantine that
we've had on a national basis the
recession
the george floyd and then the winds are
starting to change
because it seems that in terms of the
virus the lockdown
the violence they're being recalibrated
in the water's mind
and so trump as the captain can't get up
on the mast and take a knife and cut
holes in his sail and let those
tailwinds go through
and that's a metaphor for what tweeting
about joe scarborough or jeff
sessions or that dirty dog hillary as he
says
so that's not wise if he
and you can see that his team has been
more disciplined
though they're saying to him we're on a
trajectory of insidious
incremental change in people's attitudes
given the violence and
and these issues i'm going to go through
them very quickly
and you can't disrupt that tailwind
and he's been pretty much far more
disciplined
people that are on his team that are the
more disciplined and the more sober and
judicious i'm talking about mike pompeo
or
attorney general barr or ben carson
they're taking a greater role
and it presents a more professional team
than scaramucci or omarosa
or all the rest of them and that's
helped him
and you can start to pick up little
senses
something's going on and you can look at
sales of
real estate in the in downtown major
cities people are leaving
you can see gun sales at a record level
you can see the nba viewership is at a
record low
so you get the impression that people
they're anxious and they're going to do
something but they don't want to talk
about it
and what that something is i think
i'd like to go through now if you look
at the main
issue of our our time it's covered 19
and it doesn't really matter you can go
back and forth that trump had a travel
ban
biden criticize it trump said it was
like a bad flu but then nancy pelosi
invited people to come into
chinatown right during the worst
beginning of it
you can go back and forth the fact is
that
if you look at the number of dead per
million in the united states and you
compare them with the uk
spain italy uh we're about a little
we're france is catching up again we
were better than france and germany is
an outlier it's
pretty good but we're doing about what
europe does a little better
and we have a lot more challenges i
think in some ways
than europe does but my point is that
doesn't matter the
the commander in chief whether it's
katrina or the iraq war whether it goes
bad or good
the person gets the blame as you know in
recessions and depression
and so everybody blamed trump and he was
reduced to typhoid mary
but we're in the second spike now
and cases have gone down for 32 straight
days
we don't know this virus is like a you
know it's like a torpedo that's that
it's taken off on its own course you
have no idea what's going to do at any
given time
but the point is that people are getting
the impression
that whatever happened in the past we're
getting closer to a vaccine
the treatments are getting better and
maybe the virus itself
is bumping into more people six million
people have had it and people suggest
maybe 60 million
have had antibodies and don't even know
it or they have t cells so we're getting
not to hurt immunity but to areas where
it's not going to be as
and that will help the incumbent that's
a tailwind
in the next 60 days and
the recession this is the first time i
and my memory the united states has had
a self-induced recession
it's taken one of the most vibrant and
dynamic
economies in its history and it's
deliberately shut it down for
logical purposes but nevertheless it was
self-induced
that's important to remember because
there was not a structural flaw in the
economy there wasn't a run on the banks
there wasn't a
property bubble and that suggests that
it can come back and it can even come
back with a roar
if people have pin-up demand and you're
starting to see a little bit
of that already and i think that will
continue to get better so that's an
issue that i
think would help trump the
lockdown obviously hurt him
whether even though it was up to the
individual states but the lockdown is
starting to be recalibrated
not whether we're going to stay in our
house all day long but whether 50
million children can't go back to school
50 million children that have about 1
in 5 000 chances of being seriously ill
from this virus
unlike the rest of us which is probably
about one
to five and a hundred depending on our
age and core morbidity but what i'm
getting at is that
a lot of parents feel that they're going
crazy with their kids in the house
and they can't really get back to work
fully what they have to babysit and that
issue
favors the candidate that says let's go
do it let's get back
open the school that can change you
could have another third wave
plagues it seems don't have third waves
in their first year but
it could happen but that favors trump
as well the big thing though the issue
right now
is the aftermath of the george
floyd killing and if you look at the
rating of blm
after floyd's killing death however you
want to characterize on the 25th of may
by june 10th
about 70 percent of americans were not
really aware of the marxist origins of
blm but they were favorable
that's now below 50 percent it's taken a
great dive in other words
when people look at the million-dollar
mile being looted or santa monica's
downtown being trashed or
people trying to roast policemen alive
in their precinct in portland
they don't see signs with george floyd
we're doing this it's now
a antifa blm riot
and there's no sympathy and that's
across the racial ethnic gender spectrum
and it's just a question of how the
president handles it
seems to me that it's been pretty wise
he's taken the lincoln approach of
1860-61
saying i'm not going to go down in the
south and precipitate
the civil war but i am going to protect
fort sumner or
federal armory or my property trump said
something was really interesting you
said
gavin newsom doesn't run yosemite that's
our federal property and we can tell you
to go in
to yosemite not him and that and being
selective like that is very wise
because it puts the onus on the local
person for the the violence but yet it
shows that he's concerned
at the same time the attorney general is
looking for federal indictments
and you can see that there is a profile
of the antifa to take one example
protester this is not a revolutionary
shay guevara wants to go up in the
mountains with an ar-15 and attack you
this is a high school teacher social
worker or student
who's scared to death to get a felony on
his record because
every time he gets arrested i'm being
metaphorical or he's attacked he's he
almost goes into a fetal position
and starts crying stop there or when
he's attacked by a counter protester
where's the police so you get the the
impression that this is
a product of a lack of deterrence and
when the ag
starts to indict people with serious
federal consequences
and it won't be up to a local prosecutor
to drop the charges i think that
also will win approval and will be
effective
let me just pause for a minute and
suggest that these are not my
impressions these are impressions
that we know in ways that even trump the
narrowing in the polls
remember pollsters like reuters
or new york times they have political
agendas and they can warp those polls by
phrasing the question a particular way
or choosing either registered voters or
all residents or likely voters
and that will that will leverage or warp
the result
and that's not counting the woke people
who actually tabulated
who knows what they do but there's some
polls that
can't be warped and those are the
internal polls all of you if you
if you've gone to a surgeon or
oncologist you don't pay him good money
for him to lie to you and say you don't
have cancer when you do
that's what a internal poster is you pay
him money
he gets in a quiet room he closes the
door and he says look
you are going to lose michigan if you
don't and that's what's happening
and that's reflected when nancy pelosi
says i think we should cancel the debate
hillary clinton says i think he should
never concede if he loses
don lemon on cnn says i think it's time
to talk about the violence
michelle obama and barack obama said
you've got to vote gotta go vote vote
everybody
that shows you that they are reacting to
an internal accurate poll
they paid good money that shows the race
is probably within the margin of error
another is vegas better bettors don't
have any ideology their ideology they
worship money
and if you looked at what it was three
or four weeks ago
80 percent of the bets were on biden and
uh biden not to use the better
terminology but in
layman's term was about a 60 40
preference of the bettors they thought
that was going to happen now it's dead
even
and over 80 percent of the bets are
going on
trump and that shows you that people who
are not
uh political and they don't really care
who wins
but they want to give accurate
information because they're getting paid
to do it
have seen something and it's these
change in these issues
another is the vp selection i don't
can't think in my memory of vice
president ever
and a presidential candidate who was a
certain nominee
said in advance the gender of his select
uh money mate he did
and i think he thought it might be
elizabeth warren but then he didn't
anticipate the george floyd
and pretty soon he was told that it
would be african-american so then
there's african-american
women and there are no governors and
there's only maybe two senators i think
tammy duckworth has
some african-american ancestry but
but it was really kamala harris the rest
of people had not been vetted we don't
really get mayors
as vice president it's very rare to have
a house representative and camala harris
had only got two percent of the vote
and she was a very controversial upper
middle class
person whose parents were both phds
masquerading as sort of an inner city
child
and she'd accused joel biden of being a
racist and
basically de facto and the race so she
was an off-putting person and there was
a reason why she exited the race
at two percent popularity and those
traits i think are already starting to
resurface so that was not a wise
uh selection then there's the biden
paradox
uh trump is not careful when he makes
fun of the cognitive limitations of
what he calls sleepy joe biden thing
about these epithets i saw some of you
laugh
i'd always play a trick on my daughter
who was very critical of trump
and so i always say
i hate these epithets too paulie i
really hate
little marco and
crooked hillary and low energy jeb and i
see her start laughing
and when she starts laughing it hits
some
it hits a nerve because she's told me
it's not nice to do that yet she's
laughing
and i think that was the key to the
cunning of trump that he has ability to
identify a weakness and to exploit it in
a very
cruel but often real way and
the the problem with biden is that
sticks he's not
cognitively as a person it's not a
matter of age
there's people 90 95 that are far
far more hailed than he is but
what i'm getting at is what do you do
when you know your candidate
is not going to perform i've used a
metaphor before but in
when winston churchill was first lord of
the admiralty he said a very funny thing
they were boycotting the kaisers germany
and running a sea embargo it was
critical and they stopped any german
ships from coming near britain
and they were it was very important to
supply the troops at the psalm in
belgium and france
from england and had the u-boats or
german destroyers
interrupted that they would have lost
the war and admiral jelico
and so somebody's mentioned jelico and
churchill said he's the only man that
can lose the war in the afternoon
joe biden is the only candidate in u.s
history that can lose the
the election in five seconds if they let
him out
he can say at any given time he can say
almost anything he says you ain't black
one more time
and that that poll today that said 25
of african-americans will soar he says
to a
african-american journalist be like me
calling you a junkie
or a cocaine addict he's going to lose
the election you don't want
i think he already has by alienating a
large percentage of the african-american
vote
but nonetheless what do you do when a
person has a cognitive
impairment and yet because of an
unforeseen
series of circumstances the rise of
bernie sanders again nobody thought he'd
be a threat again
you bring in michael bloomberg to save
michael bloomberg was a billion-dollar
dud
and then you've got who left beto or
kamel
uh camilla or cory booker or butterjig
so everybody said get them all out of
the race immediately
and we'll use biden and he'll be sort of
a vessel
but the problem with that is you you
didn't and then the covet thing was very
fortunate because it was a virtual
campaign and he's been in his basement
for night but what do you do now
do you put joe biden out in a debate
and he you risk him saying some things
are pretty crazy like he did yesterday
one time he was out and he was on the
teleprompter and he said you know
a hundred people have been killed 100
years have been killed this year nobody
knew what he was talking about
but if you don't put him in the debate
you've got a sort of a clint eastwood
2012 convention where trump
you know trump you'll go out there and
talk to an empty chair
if you if you
put him out and say you know what trump
is a madman the guy is out there
he sleeps for he scarfs down a big mac
and then he
sleeps four hours and he's all over the
country
so we got to match him you got to have
tarmac rallies
you have to have unscripted interviews
you have to
have press conferences well you can't do
that
and yet if you don't do that he's just
covering ground that you can't cover
and so because of the nature of his
candidate
candidacy he hasn't he hasn't condemned
the violence
at all until recently and he
contextualizes it he says well you know
the police did this and police did this
but looting is bad
but but but sort of and the reason he
can't is he made a
devil's bargain faustian bargain
with a hard left of his party and he
said
they basically said to him you're going
to be
the centrist prop that's going to get us
elected
and in exchange for that we're going to
create a sense of chaos in these cities
with
the enabling of the blue state mayors
and governors and that sense of anarchy
will be blamed on the chief executive
but in return for that
once you're president you're going to
have the new green deal the aoc
sanders ticket that was sort of
blackmailing all of us because when
biden had said earlier well the violence
will stop
when i'm present i think it would
because i think all these people said
we'll stop now because he's going to
give us this agenda
so he can't criticize them and yet he
has to criticize them
and now people are getting angry and
it's a negative for him and yet to do
that
breaks this unspoken bargain with blm
so he's got he's got himself into a
series of
paradoxes he's a prisoner of paradox and
i don't know how he squares that circle
but it'll be interesting to see
there's also a lot of known unknowns
i didn't think that in october the
democrats
after all the stuff that came out about
donald trump i didn't know they had a
10-year access hollywood
to jump out on right before the debate
did you hours before the debate
the only miscalculation was that most
people would have gone into a fetal
position and said oh my gosh
trump got up and smiled and said i'll
have a good debate and he got steve
bannon they brought in
all of bill's former liaisons and they
paraded him right in front of hillary
and she kept looking like this so
but that kind of thing and i think
george bush would have won the popular
vote in 2000
had they not sprung his dui he never
told anybody about 48 hours before the
election
made him look duplicitous so that can
happen
there can be a very embarrassing
something about either candidate
or china who i think does not want
donald trump
it could it could go in and send a
missile over taiwan
or bump into a japanese ship or do
something with australia
very easy or putin we don't know where
he is at any one time
he could do something in belarus and
that's happened before
and so there's no we'll call them known
unknowns and they'll be a predicator and
that's a neutral thing that's not going
to help either candidate we now
it will eventually
i think there's also something that
we've talked about and that is a stealth
voter
i have a feeling it's just my impression
that most of you will probably vote for
trump
but i also have a certainty that you're
not going to be very vocal about it
in fact i will bet you that in your
circle of friends that once you were
asked you either lied or you were quiet
because you know that it's not worth the
social opinion
that people are going to demonize you
that you're worried
when you get a text and say will you
answer a poll or a phone call you think
i'm not going to answer that
knowing what silicon valley does with
data i might be on some list
so there is a two to three to four
percent people argue about it
stealth trump vote and i think
uh the democrats know that very well and
they they
if you talk to some of their handlers
they will say if we're down
in our polls two percent in michigan
then trump's going to win
uh excuse me if trump's down two he's
going to win we have to have him down
three to four to five
that's an issue the uh
this is our first if you notice this is
our first virtual election we've ever
had
it's first virtual candidate in joe
biden first virtual campaign i've never
seen anything like it
he's he hasn't campaigned at all nobody
knows what he's for
other than he says he's for the agenda
and even the dnc did you know they never
mentioned the agenda
because they didn't want you to know
what it was you don't want to tear down
the wall
nobody wants a wealth tax nobody wants
40
income tax nobody wants to ban coal or
ban natural gas or fracking or
horizontal drilling
medicare for everybody free health care
for illegal aliens
that's an issue that never pulls 50 on
any one of those
items and so
it's kind of virtual we don't hear about
that and they were very fortunate they
being the democrats that
this lockdown came because it was
tailor-made
for joe biden and all he had to do was
let trump
take the blame both as the
commander-in-chief as i mentioned
and then trump's tweets it was a very
good strategy we didn't even know
who biden was we never saw him when we
saw him it was a disaster so we saw him
even less the next time
and we never knew what the agenda was
and he was eight nine points ahead
the only problem as i said earlier is
that eventually you have to have a real
campaign it can be the last day but at
some point the american people
want to see what he was for and who he
is and does he still exist
and that hurt trump that virtual
campaign
and where we are now as far as a virtual
campaign there's two items that are i
think will help adjudicate the election
and that is
whether we will have debates or not
nancy pelosi suddenly agreed with tom
friedman we won't
and joe biden i think said at one point
yes we're going to have debates but
we're going to have fact checkers
that's sort of like the candy crawly
remember that with mitt romney she's
going to be the moderator and say stop
mr trump that's a lie and joe that
that was pretty much true but keep it up
a little bit
clean it up so that could be that
but the most important thing is it's
going to be a male
mail-in ballot election if it's an
absentee nobody cares it won't affect it
either way with normal absentees
but if polls in some of these states are
not going to be open at all and the
states remember under the constitution
control
the method in which the election is
conducted
that's going to be a big problem i'm
speaking to somebody in the 21st
congressional district in california
when our
three-term incumbent david valdeo won by
53 percent on election day
and nearing christmas 30 days later
he lost by 600 votes by something we
call in california
third party voting or third party vote
gathering or
you know it better and the colloquial is
vote harvesting
where state agencies get names sometimes
of name
in some cases in california if i'm
victor hansen i go to the dmv and i say
i'm victor d hanson
i go the state disability i get i say
i'm v d
hanson another one i'm saying vic hansen
and all the ballots come to the same
address
somebody shows up because it's public
knowledge and says here's your
registration forms give them to me
i'll fill them out i'll take them and
register and i'll be back
in a week with the ballot the ballots
will arrive i'll be back to pick them up
and that was very effective and the
republicans had no idea
it was coming because they didn't do it
in the primaries
and so it was very effective and
california has seven out of 53
congressional seats that are republican
it destroyed the republican party and
the congr
congress in california and it has super
majorities in
both legislatures and it doesn't have
one
national statewide i should say
candidate
a office holder that's republican so it
was very effective
and that could be a an important
criterion
the most important though is
what makes this different from the 1960s
election 68 you saw that the democratic
convention in chicago mayor daley except
remember that some of us
and there was all this turmoil but what
was different was the democratic mayors
of those cities
tried to keep order they sent the police
out they condemned the violence
we've never seen a situation in my
lifetime where the
chief of police in some cases but surely
the local district attorneys the mayors
the state
city council are actively on the side of
the people perpetuating the violence
and they're trying to excuse it and
they're trying to contextualize it in
league with
the new york times the washington post
pbs npr
abc nbc cbs msnbc cnn
it's a fusion and it's got enormous
influence
and we've never quite seen that before
part of it is because of the hatred of
trump but part of it is
the democratic party is not the party
that we used to remember
the party of the middle class now the
working class if you look at all the
statistics
you look at zip codes red blue by income
it's the republican party it's the party
of people who make
forty five thousand to two hundred
thousand there are wealthy people of
course but the real
big money in america now it's not from
real estate necessarily it's not from
mining or timber or agriculture or
railroad it's from high tech
finance wall street uh silicon valley
and it's all left wing
go look at the fortune 500 and look at
the names on there and see
what their political affiliations are if
you know them it's predominantly
left-wing so the democratic party has a
very strange alliance from the very
wealthy and the very poor the wealthy
are always
immune from the consequences of their
own ideology they have the
power the influence and the hypocrisy to
want
to tear down borders have no walls and
then have the biggest wall you can
imagine around the state of mark
zuckerberg
or nancy pelosi can tell everybody you
better wear a mask trump is not wearing
a mask and sneak into a salon
as she did in san francisco without a
mask and have a secret
stealthy hairdo or gavin newsom can give
us lectures about
you've got to shut down all the wineries
of course mine won't be shut down
and that's sort of part and parcel of
this new
progressive ideology that our our aims
are so noble
and we want such perfect egalitarianism
and equality
that we are allowed to use any means
necessary to achieve them
because when we get them then we're
going to be you know
saints but we might have to break a few
eggs on the way up
and that allows a person to do some
pretty terrible things so what i'm
getting at is that we have a
democratic party that has
metamorphosized into a party of
huge amounts of wealth and influence
silicon valley
hollywood new york tv programming
the media the universities the
foundation the celebrity culture
professional sports it's it's a
conglomerate
and it includes everybody from mark
zuckerberg to bill gates to lebron james
think of it and that very wealthy class
that
influential celebrity group that's
so popular in our culture is
dedicated believe it or not to radically
changing
not just america but the structure of
america so it doesn't
it can't revert back to america now i
want to finish by what do i mean
if joe biden were to win
and if he were to win i think he would
take the u.s senate
i don't think he'd take it by a lot i
think he'd have 51 or 52
democrats the first thing they do would
be eliminate the filibuster
if they held the house and the president
the second i think the first thing they
do and they
all 15 democratic candidates said they
wanted to pack the supreme court
it's not in the constitution the number
it's been nine since 1867 but they could
have 15 they said 15.
they could vote that through the senate
and the house and the biden would sign
it and they would
they would appoint six justices and they
could be confirmed without a filibuster
by 51 people in the senate no problem
and i think that we'd see that i think
the electoral college would be dead we'd
never see it again
you don't have everybody says well it's
a it's in the constitution
you have to amend it well in the same
world you do
but all you need is 270 votes of
individual states
who say and we've already got what 230
of
electoral votes in these states these
blue states that said
whom whoever wins the national vote
our state pledges that our electors
shall not vote
on the state tally but they'll reflect
the national vote
and when you get to 270 you only you
only need about half the states
and then the electoral college is dead
and some of you are going to say well
that's a compact between states that's
unconstitutional
well not if the supreme court is altered
supreme court determines
what's constitutional and not on
unconstitutional
if you read what they say they're
attacking the very structure of having
two u.s senators
why does wyoming one senator represents
225
000. poor little victor hit my senator
i have to share camilla harris and
dianne feinstein would
each each one is 20 million that's not
fair
i think that we should make senators
redistrib
distributed like house representatives
so california should have what 30
and maybe wyoming zero or one and
i think that if you look at the
literature people are already talking
about that so what i'm getting at
is and i won't even get into immigration
because we have taken
the distinction between a u.s citizen
and a resident it used to be
crystal clear residents had these rights
but they paled in comparison with
citizens rights if you look at what they
are now
they're basically three rights that a
resident doesn't have
illegal or legal a resident supposedly
cannot vote
an election but they can now vote as
they're doing in san francisco
in cambridge and local school board
election and you know what's going to
follow from that
they supposedly cannot hold office we've
had people
appointed to positions in california
there are offices
that are not here legally they're
residents but illegal residents
and they have to they cannot get a u.s
passport
but i'm not sure that we really care
when a resident comes in and out of the
country without a passport anymore
and so what i'm getting at is that this
election
is not just about a democrat taking
power and then a republican coming in
and vice versa
this is not a democratic versus a
republican this is a progressive
radical revolutionary effort to change
the structure
of a constitutional republic that was
deliberately founded
to protect the people
with the bill of rights the amendments
protect the people from
the mob it wasn't an athenian style
democracy that's what the
founders they want that they do not want
the american revolution they do not like
jefferson or washington or madison they
want their statute they like the french
revolution and i'll end with that very
eerie
and that that sounds this guy's
hysterical what you're saying
what were the two symbols in the last
two demonstrations
a guillotine the guillotine the present
symbology
and so i think this is the one time a
person could say without bombast or
exaggeration
this is one of the four or five most
important elections in our history
thank you very much
i don't know if uh i spoke too long do
we have quite time for questions if
anybody has a question
we have i don't hear all that well but
go ahead
did everybody hear the question could
you comment on the african-american vote
uh today there was a poll that came out
that suggested that uh
25 of the black vote
would go to uh donald trump
that's important because he only got
eight percent in 2016 and the way and
it's a very important because this
election is not going to be
decided in my state it's not going to be
incited in alabama it's not going to be
cited in new york it's going to be
decided here pennsylvania wisconsin
minnesota
arizona florida and the way that this
dynamic has shifted is
these big cities cleveland
pittsburgh detroit philadelphia
milwaukee madison columbus cleveland
they are at odds with the suburbs but
especially rural areas
people like hillsdale county and the way
it works is obama
was able to get 95
of the african-american vote up to 97
percent and get
record registration and record turnout
the black vote in 2008 was
the turnout was higher than the white
vote
but that's very important because each
year since then
the number of voters who call themselves
middle class in general and white
in particular that vote democratic has
gone down
so the reliance on the black vote goes
up for a democrat
and most people think the threshold is
about
12 to 13 and with a latino vote
somewhere between 35 and 40 percent
when a republican gets to that level
there's not going to be enough
minority and that also suggests another
thing that if people are
pulling that way there's not going to be
enthusiasm
in general to vote for biden and maybe
they won't come out but my point is
that if that that poll were accurate and
there'd been others like it
then they don't have the nucleus or the
calculus i should say are the analytics
to balance the rural areas and the
conservative areas of these purple
states
and i think that's why they're paranoid
and i think that's why we hear trump's
racist trumps a racist
trump's a racist and
why is that black vote there
why is why is somebody that the bush
family
and the romney family and the mccain
family is a racist getting
three times higher black support than
any of those candidates
there has to be reason and one of course
was the record it was record
black unemployment 5.4
never seen anything like it trump took
whatever your views are on sentencing
and drug
reductions for drug offenses he took and
pardons
he took the initiative when you looked
at the rnc convention i never saw
anything like it
i thought isn't somebody going to say we
need more millionaires like george bush
said
george h.w isn't somebody say that the
whole
election will hinge on the capital gain
stack no
they had all these middle class people
up there that had these stories
and if you looked at it analytically he
turned the republican party
into a class party so he was saying that
we are the worker
nationalist populist working people's
party and we don't have the celebrities
we don't have
the silicon valley grandest like the dnc
they had all these movie stars
and the effect of that was to
say to people that of all different
races your class
ties are more solidifying than your
racial differences
and that affected a lot of
african-americans and i think the
looting has had an
adverse effect on joe biden in the
minority community so what i'm getting
at is i think that's very important
and and you can i know it's important
and you know it's important because
you're going to hear in the next three
weeks
that donald trump is a klansman he's a
racist he's [ __ ] and they're going to
try to do anything they can
to get that vote away yes historically
is
yeah i think
i think that put it this way
that rise in the stock market in an
election has not always been
an absolute indicator who's going to win
but it has been a pretty accurate
indicator of what people thought the
economy would be like after the next
president was elected
and this rise in the stock market what
i'm getting at there'll be people
if we were to go to goldman sachs and
poll a thousand goldman i think the
majority were going to vote for biden
if we were going to poll them and say
what's your stock strategy from now
until november
they would adjudicate it based on trump
in other words they will tell everybody
that
i think they're voting against trump but
hoping he wins
is what i'm getting at yes
well everybody everybody here the
question that
under the constitution as i mentioned
earlier
the founders were very worried they were
classical scholars they had read
thucydides they had read plato they knew
who executed socrates
it was the democracy so and they looked
at the roman tripartite model of
judiciary executive legislative checks
and they liked it
and then that tradition had been
prominent with montesquieu and
in the french enlightenment but
nevertheless what i'm getting at is that
they put as you pointed out into the
constitution checks on popular
frenzies one of them was they let states
predicate
who could vote they had a property
qualification in most states
that was done with the senators were
supposed to
be selected by the legislature
not the people that was overturned i
think in 1916 or 415
was it on their progressive agenda and
that's gone and you
suggested maybe we should go back but
the trajectory of all democratic
experiments are and this is not my idea
plato said
if i can be so crass he said he has
socrates saying
at one point in a famous passage
well gorgeous your democracy is going to
let these people vote this
and when do the dogs and the donkeys
vote and he was being cruel and cynical
but what he meant was the logic of
egalitarianism
has no end and so when i mention
you say you're worried that we now
popularly elect
senators i'm worried that they're going
to make at best
senators proportioned on the uh
population of the state and worse
they're going to just take them away and
not even give them one
and so we're moving in that direction
and if you look at a lot of things
in the constitution there they're no
longer there
uh impeachment now no longer means high
crimes and misdemeanors or bribery and
treason
i don't know about you but i don't i've
never heard of anybody arrested
pulled over by a highway patrolman and
said you're guilty of abuse of power and
obstructing
the congress that's what he was
impeached on it wasn't even a crime
but my point is impeachment now is just
what madison said in the federalist
papers it's
fatal that the out party will try to
when they get a call hold of a majority
in the house they will impeach the
president for political reason
and he outlined exactly what happened in
2019 and 20. so yeah you got a really
good point
yes
yeah in the old days the guy who raised
the most money often won
although i think it was john conley had
i don't know how he had one delegate in
the nomination he spent
millions of bills look at michael
bloomberg 1 billion and what did it get
him
but that old way of you hire all of
these
consultants you come in you have these
60-second tv
ads that has been changed
and that's because we have sophisticated
data
in silicon valley i'll give you an
example what i mean i won't mention any
names
but i was seated in september of 2016 at
a dinner
and one of the most renowned political
figures in
in our history was there with another
very famous person for silicon valley
and that person turned to me and said
shame on you for voting for donald trump
he has no
idea how to run a campaign he's going to
lose
he doesn't understand data hillary's got
robbie mook
running his campaign he's got the tech
wizards they're young
they're hip they got facebook and this
other person
was listening to this and i
i saw him scowl and so this very
renowned gentleman turned him and said
what are you scaling out he said you
know where hillary is
going to be she's going to be in georgia
and arizona
on a don quixote quest to get a
landslide mandate she's never going to
take those states
and we are the proverbial fox in the hen
house and we have data on every single
person who did not vote
in the 2008 or 2012 election there's
four to six million of them
and we're going to beat the romney we i
thought wow he's silicon valley what's
he mean by we
but i was listening he said we're going
to beat we're going to get 4 to 6
million you can call him what you want
he said to this gentleman
call him a parole voter call him a
reagan democrat call them a deplorable
i don't care but we're going to get them
out they've
checked out and we're going to get them
out with china we're going to get them
back
out with border we're going to get them
back out with reindustrializing
the west no more afghanistan it went
through the hall and this guy got kind
of angry and he said how would you know
i won't say his name because you'd all
recognize it he said because i designed
the system
and i've got the most sophisticated
people in silicon valley and they've
contacted now
five times those four to six million
people and you wait till election day
and i just
i turned him and i said you're going to
win michigan
he said the question's not where they're
going to win michigan it's whether we're
going to win minnesota
and as you know they came within two
points of winning it so that's what the
election is about now
it's targeting people with electronic
selectivity and
repeated messaging and finding which
many little groups
this appeals to and the idea of trump
the buffoon and
sloppy doesn't belies the fact that he
actually has very
good as good as biden's
analytics from silicon valley any other
questions
yeah right here
i don't know the answer to that um
the question was why wasn't candace
owens invited to speak at the republican
i think maybe that her former
partnership with charlie cook
kirk i don't know what happened but that
dissipated but i don't think it hurt her
because
she's being louded to the skies when you
see these poles of african-american and
the brexit i mean the blacks that she
said
so she was kind of the architect of that
but i don't know the inner
politic politics of that she's a very
effective spokeswoman
for the republican party and i have a
feeling she's going to play a prominent
role in the campaign
and he oh yeah
well in the old days a republican would
have said this
when we had to lock down the covet and
the unemployment he said listen damn it
we already were running a trillion
dollar death i would have said that
we're already running a trillion dollar
deficit now we're up to 26 trillion
dollars almost
we're broke and we're going to have what
are we going to do have zero interest
for the rest of our lives to service
that debt that's taking money from
people who have pass book accounts that
work their whole life
they've got a hundred thousand dollars
and they lose money because inflation
eats it up and they get
zero or one percent with that's
intolerable
not trump this guy hates banks
he's declared bankrupt his idea is
somebody comes to him and says
let's let's inflate the economy let's
give people as much
staying home to get through it we'll
we'll get four million and then we'll
get the economy roaring and we'll have
arthur laffer and we'll pay it all back
and then we'll get tough and cut
i don't think that's going to happen but
that was a republican who bought that
and i will concede that it kept the
economy liquid
and so even though we've had a terrible
recession
we haven't had a recession in my
hometown the biggest joke is
you talk to people and they said i'll
say you know amazon has signs hiring
they have all these things yeah but i
don't want to take a pay cut
they're making as much staying home but
that has greased the economy
and it's added four trillion dollars of
the debt
and i think trump he's not
i think people who have talked to him
will tell you that he said the money is
free
for now so if you actually look at the
percentage of the
of the budget that has to service this
huge debt
once interest rates went to one or two
percent
it didn't really go up much as a
percentage of the federal budget
compared to where we had a much smaller
national debt but we were paying seven
and eight on t bills or even 10.
so we know what's coming we're either
going to have to
debase the currency or we're going to
have to have a terrible recession
to address it and run surpluses
or we're going to uh have quantitative
easing and so
increase the money supply or we're going
to have rampant inflation
it's going to be one of those
35 yes old never trump daughter
who fancies herself
using your
i have nothing to tell you because uh
i'm a twin brother of somebody who voted
for bernie sanders
so obviously i failed in that category
and then i will go a step further
in saying that of my immediate siblings
i am the black sheep pariah i mean they
they are much more persuasive with them
than me but all i
i try to say if that's any help that you
could tell her that
this isn't about trump's personality
this is not about
george bush versus al gore it's not even
barack obama versus john mccain this is
about
a radical hijacking of the democratic
party
and this is telling people that we are
going to take the first amendment as you
know and it's not going to apply on
campuses
we're going to take the second amendment
as the founders envision
it's not going to apply anymore the
supreme court is not going to look the
same
that statue in your park is going to be
gone that
1776 date and your mind is going to be
orwellian erased it's going to be 1619.
we are going to change the statues when
it's changed thought movie you think you
want to watch
turner classic movies and see gone with
a win it's not going to be there when we
get in there
this is an effort to systematically in a
trotskyite fashion erase our collective
memory and our values
and replace it with a totalitarian
radical french revolutionary jacobin
model and i have never seen anything
like it and i lived through the 60s
one more any final yes right there
so what is behind the antifa blm
model well we know the short term i mean
i'm i'm trying to be fair to them
i don't think they would have been as
effective or frenzied had we not had
the fear of the virus 90 days of
lockdown
recession let's add in 1.5 trillion
dollars in student loans
for degrees that were pretty much
worthless and end up
a lot of these people are looking at 80
000 at sixty
six percent why they work as a barista
with a sociology or environmental
distillation degrees so they're angry
they're angry because if you look at
homeownership the age of marriage the
age of childbearing the age of buying a
first home it's all
wacko so today's pajama boy in that
commercial or life of julia
is a ward of the state these are people
who
if they do get married they get married
in their 30s if they do have a child
it's one child when they're 40.
when they do buy a home it's you know
it's a little cottage that cost a
thousand dollars a square foot in san
francisco or something
so they're not happy and i don't blame
them for that reason that being said
what what do they they've been i don't i
think
this didn't happen right now a lot of
people at hillsdale especially have been
warning
what has been going on k-12 and what's
been going on to college
so i i was a professor and i'm in
academia i can tell you that
they have been indoctrinating people and
saying the corporation
your religion your community are all
biased so we're going to be biased to
balance them
and we're going to turn you out as a
woke deductive thinker and we're not
and these people are very arrogant and
they're very ignorant when they go and
tear down a statue named lee and they
congratulate themselves and it's not
robert e lee it's
jc lee of world war ii who was a
logistician
you know how stupid they are or they try
to deface frederick douglass
statue or they say they're anti-fascists
and they attacked the world war ii
monument for people who destroyed
fascism
so they're they're very ignorant they're
very arrogant they're very young
and they're very angry and they're
jealous and envious
and they're confused but most important
you remember that line and dirty harry
when
dirty harry says the zodiac is going to
kill again
and that kind of bureaucratic ignoramus
that's his bosses
how do you know that harry and he said
because he likes it
and they like it they like going out
there they're getting paid with this
the support and they know that nothing's
going to happen to them
if one of them two of them three of them
four of them find out they have a
federal felony warrant out for their
arrest
if the police decide to crack down
have you seen these youtubes when they
crack down they they scream in this high
nasal voice and then you
you look at them and it's the washington
post ran a photo op
a chic vogue-like photo op a
photojournalist story on them and they
had an eight of them posing there like
this
here is my green bike helmet and my pads
here's my leaf blower to blow aware tear
gas
oh here's my umbrella to stop
a tear gas uh capsules and it was all
sort of like the glorification of the
good looking sarnath brother the boston
marathon that vogue did and so
this is kind of a chic thing for these
young kids they think they look and what
are they doing when they're going in and
looting they're taking selfies on
themselves
they're posting things on the internet
they don't think
well when i get arrested i better damn
well have the fifth amendment i better
have habeas corpus i better have a right
to a speedy trial i better have a right
to counsel
they don't think that that they're
destroying that they don't think
well i have a gun that guy one of the
people had they have guns they said well
i have a right to
to carry a second they don't think that
they're destroying the very system what
they're going to be in need of when
they're in extreme
extremists so they're angry young
confused
people who have been indoctrinated for
years
and they feel there's no consequences
for destroying the system
and they're not even aware that the
system that they're destroying that
has been very good to them so they're in
on grey in greats and ungrateful
and the only thing you can do to snap
them out of their mesmerized hypnosis
is to eventually in a very selective
careful way
make them arrest arrest them when they
break the law
and charge them with federal not local
crimes
incarcerate them put it on their record
and then get
federal troops to come in when it's wise
and sober
and once you start doing that it will
dissipate
but they're not heroic people they're
not shea guevara not that i like the guy
but at least he went into bolivia with
his machine gun
and fought it out before they killed him
these people are not going into rural
utah and saying you know what
i got to get into red hillsdale county
i'm going to get my guys in there and
we're going to storm
jonesville they're going to go to
jackson they're going to take hillsdale
and fight it out with those roof
they're not going to do that thank you
you